hello folks welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics at
all okay today we have a great day we're
going to be talking a little bit about
um the block Universe we've been talking
about that lately Time time travel time
dilation a lot of that stuff that comes
out of general
relativity and we're going to see if any
of that has any validity whatsoever okay
uh first of I hope uh everybody can hear
me fine and can see me fine okay please
let me know
otherwise uh sometimes I continue
speaking I don't realize you know that
maybe the sound is off or whatever so
anyone out there please let me know
okay
um I'm going to start with the
usually the extinction segment we're
going to cover a couple things
here okay thank
you yeah I always need uh Assurance
reassurances okay okay uh fellow ask a
question about Argentina you know it's
been in the news lately and it's
somewhat uh important uh for the theory
of extinction because there's a lot of
people out there who um are what I call
Narco caps you know anarco
capitalists Anar or whatever they call
themselves I call them Narco caps
anyways uh this the uh what this F said
I wonder what you think about
fortification of system in Argentina
libertarian
[__] I mean
tyranny uh M repairs repressive forces
against popular upright ring in
Argentina okay and yeah they have new
president over there and um so the
question is you know whether this is
going to be good or bad for for the
country for Argentina right and yeah
first I want to say that I guess the one
of the reasons the fellow asked the
question is that you know I'm from
Argentina I was born in uh the southern
part of the city really in the suburb
just next to the city and uh born in
Lano 15 blocks away from where Maradona
the baseball the uh soccer player was
born he was born at the luse hospital I
was born in
luse um anyways uh another fellow that
was born in that region and also lived
in that region is my friend um Pope
Frankie okay Pope Frankie uh he was born
in Flores and uh means flowers in
Spanish and uh that's more more or less
close to my where I was born and uh even
uh better you know we have something
more in common with the Pope and that's
we're both from the same team team is
San Lorenzo which means St Lawrence you
wonder why the pope is St Lawrence yeah
it was founded by a priest the uh team
anyways um I have a little anecdote uh
involving my son my oldest son Eric and
we were in Argentina a few years back I
think about 5 years ago and uh he went
with his suit and this was a special
suit that he had made it's about a crow
that's the crow and um the crow is the
mascot of San Lorenzo that's why he
dressed up as a crow and he went to take
a picture of himself with a team so we
went to the uh Stadium San Lorenzo
stadium and uh they wouldn't let us in
in not to see the team they thought we
were spies that
were there to see how the team was
practicing and playing and so they
didn't want anybody watching that okay
and so yeah we lost hope we started
going back home and just as we were
going out here comes a team of I think
it was 10 or 15 uh people with cameras
and so on turns out it's a film crew uh
Italian and Spanish from Spain right uh
film crew that was there to film a movie
and the movie's name is Ostro Papa which
means our Pope and they were at San Leno
because the pope is from San Lorenzo
he's a fan of San Lorenzo and San
Lorenzo fans like that because they say
hey we got God on our side you know and
uh so they saw my son with the uh with
the uh Crow uh costume and he say oh we
need you we need you can you do you mind
participating in our movie and it just
came out of nowhere and so we went with
the crew and uh they filmed him you know
as part of the movie and this is more or
less what it looks like here let me show
you just a very brief uh piece of that
give me a second
here
and this is what the movie was about
Papa it talks about Pope Frankie right
and there's my son up there on the uh
you know in the stands and you can see
that uh he's dressed as a as a crow and
here you'll see him a little better and
we took a picture with the crew
afterwards there you see the
crew and uh we were all happy just
because that happened the pope blessed
us right and and then the girls all the
girls and everybody just just about
everybody wanted to have a picture with
a
crow so uh yeah um we had a lot of fun
with that and thanks to that we also got
to eat a barbecue for free we were
invited inside the club and he was able
to be at the game that uh Sunday or
Saturday or Sunday I can't remember now
which and uh you know we were there with
a crowd he was in in the Stadium they
allowed him into the stadium and he was
able to do you know uh dress up as the
mascot and so uh you know we were kind
of happy that all that happened just
happened by sure look so if you see the
movie I think it's from 2019 look it up
you noop papa Italian Spanish movie of
some kind and um I didn't see it yet
you'll see uh the crow there okay
anyways um so this V ask about Good Old
M and uh here let me show you some
headlines that came out in the last few
days about uh good old mle okay here it
is why Argentina's shock measures may be
the best hope for its alien
economy analysis of M's mission
improbable for Argentina has investors
daring to dream yeah a lot of people are
dreaming they think that maybe uh
something's going to change over there
okay anxiety and resignation in
Argentina after m economic shock
measures immediately M put all these
shock measures in place specifically the
dollar he devalued
um uh the um the the pzo you know by
raising it uh compared to the dollar it
was uh less than 400 was about 350
360 and now per dollar and now it's 800
pesos per dollar okay so he raised in
that caused a big shock because suddenly
all the prices in
Argentina uh
doubled and I got an example there for
you in a minute mleo moves to limit
anti-austerity protests in Argentina so
they're going to use some
heavy-handedness there to uh qu any
riots or any any uh you know protest and
Argentina's new presidents alarmed lgbtq
activist with closure of diverse Unity
Ministry he's even done that and uh the
previous government had a different take
on that and here a picture is worth a
thousand words and here you will see why
okay uh that's Fernandez son not
daughter but son there on the left his
name is estanislau Fernandez and he
likes to dress up as a woman and then on
the right hand side you see balaros who
was the president of Brazil at the time
uh son and uh when you compare him well
you can see why many argentines were not
very happy with that
comparison okay and so and so um you
know what what happened in the end was
that you know uh uh Fernandez was
overthrown essentially you know he was
voted out of power and we have this guy
M and yeah he's going to go against uh
all this stuff um that he thinks it's uh
not worth spending a penny on okay so uh
just new things that are going on and
obviously a big change in policy not
only that uh M um aligned himself with
the United States and with the Western
World which is a total change from uh
the Fernandez regime the two Fernandez
regimes even um even the the woman you
know Christina and they're not related
the two fernandas by the way they have
the same last name but it's a very
common name down there and so yeah you
have uh for almost 20 years you've had
the Fernandez in one way or another the
paranis in power and that's now
radically changed in the other direction
now it's conservative right you could
say conser from Liberal to conservative
and uh another important detail that's
uh important to you know keep in mind is
that M wants to be a Jew he wants to be
a uh he wants to convert
and uh that's somewhat of a problem in
Argentina because there are secret
groups you know um that are against Jews
over there and uh you know he's going to
have to deal with that a lot of military
are involved in that as well very
nationalistic very uh Ultra
nationalistic very anti-jewish
and uh you know you all kinds of groups
there and so you know
the question is whether he can continue
with this government especially with the
drastic measures he's taking and
everybody I think agrees that in the
short run things are going to be very
tough for the argentines right and I can
just give you an example that happened
to me I was there about a month ago and
uh the the trip from the airport to the
city to the center of the city by bus
the dendon which is the famous uh bus
uh route that carries people to the
center of the city uh cost $4 and it's
like a 45 minute ride so it's quite
cheap now it's $8 today okay at the
exchange rate and um and then uh there
was a we made a trip from busiris to St
Louis St Louis uh out there in the west
it's an 11-hour ride on the bus and that
cost us $25 $5 and now it costs over 50
so you can see how that's going to
impact a lot of people there and uh you
know all the prices rising and so on so
I don't know what's going to happen in
the short run there's going to be a lot
of pain and if he can withstand that you
know maybe through measures uh military
measures you know police how do you
contain the riots right um well maybe
something happens where the country
Rises back up again uh that's for us to
see you know it's like they say in the
long run but like someone Economist once
said in the long run we're all dead so
we don't know about the long run but the
short run there's going to be a lot of
pain and probably there's going to be a
lot of burning of tires and breaking of
Windows you know riots okay so here's
one uh one of the problems that M has
and that's got he's got a 400 billion
Deb bomb okay he's got to you got to
deactivate that bomb and I don't know if
he'll be able to um they owe like 50
billion to uh the monetary fund the
international monetary fund and in fact
today uh or yesterday I think he got a
uh a loan from uh South
American conglomerate there for 1
billion and so he says hey that's I'm
already on top I've already achieved
something and maybe he does I don't know
uh it wasn't good for me because when I
was there a month ago I paid everything
very very cheaply and now if I go there
it's going to be a lot more expensive so
for me it wasn't good I mean damn the
country the country is you know a
problem for the people in Argentina you
know no doubt about it they're GNA
suffer and they were suffering here it
comes this fellow and he just changes it
he just drops a bomb on everybody you
know so it's going to be tough and I
don't know if they can recover from that
but we'll find out right the point here
is that for me it's not good simply
because you know when you go there with
dollars or Euros you know you can
stretch them quite you know everything's
very cheap and now it's less cheap you
know so for me it wasn't good but you
know that's that's the
breaks okay and uh here's another uh
headline there it says he has there's no
alternative to shock treatment he says
there's no
money essentially that's what he told
the public inflation's at 143% 43
billion in debt um and it says uh he's
in aarco capitalist uh which I call
Narco caps right and says currently $1
is worth uh 385 that's what it was worth
until he came and now um uh he changed
that to 800 so now a dollar in the
official Market is $800 800 pesos and so
he doubled it and that's what causes
caused all the prices to Skyrocket and
yeah uh if you go to
Argentina uh mark my words I haven't
done it I've you know for the last 40 50
years I've never exchanged at the uh
official rate never never use credit
cards not in Argentina you'd be very
stupid to do so why because always the
black market gives you more than what
the government gives you and there's a
thriving Black Market Market has been
there for a long time and they never
give you fake bills they try to scare
you say he you might get a fake Bill no
you never get a fake bill because they
make enough money as it is they don't
need to put fake bills into circulation
if anyone it's the government who puts
fake bills into
circulation anyways uh so what is a
narco cap Narco capitalist which is what
this mil fellow says he is okay and here
he is this comes from the Wikipedia
Narco capitalism or they say anap but I
prefer Narco right is an anti-statist
libertarian political philosophy and
economic theory that seeks to abolish
what centralized States in favor of
stateless societies with systems of
private property enforced by private
agencies the non-aggression principle
free markets and self-ownership which
extends the concept to include control
of private property as part of the self
ahuh But Here Comes com the nice part
says in the absence of Statute anarch
capitalist hold that Society tends to
contractually self-regulate and
civilized TR participation in the free
market which they describe as voluntary
Society involving the what voluntary
exchange of goods and services in a
theoretical anarcho Capital Society the
system of private property would still
exist and be enforced by what private
defense agencies private defense
agencies and or
in insurance companies selected by
customers which would operate
competitively in a market and fulfill
the roles of Courts and the justice so
the question is you know who are they
going to hire I mean Ivan the Terrible
uh or what AA thean Jenis can uh who who
are these uh private companies that
they're going to you know hire to
protect you uh I can only be very very
extremely skeptical of Narco caps uh
it's a lot of the people who especially
the young youth the Young Generation who
are so fed up with government
intervening in their lives and telling
them you got to get a vaccine and you
know all this kind of stuff that what
what has happened they've gone the other
way and say we don't want any more
government we're sick of government and
they're all politician they're all
Crooks you know and so people have lost
confidence in the politicians and they
don't want them anymore and they say
look I hate for government to come here
and tax me when I can just reach a deal
with my neighbor and and exchange
something with him you know he he wants
my table and I want his TV so we trade
it's a voluntary exchange that's the way
they want it you know and the problem I
see at least the overall problem is that
first this is
microeconomics and what this guy mle is
doing is he's doing macroeconomics he's
going to be applying this to the whole
country that's one issue and they're not
the same thing you know one thing is to
trade with your neighbor without
government intervention in fact that's
what happens with the peso versus the
dollar you know you go out in the street
you exchange with someone and he gives
you peso you give him a dollar and he
gives you more pesos than the government
very simple it's a narco capit it's best
you know but uh the question is you know
these people live under the umbrella of
government and it's easy to trade and do
all that stuff when you have a
government when you have already a
society running and these people say
we're going to get rid of government you
know and do it on our own we we want
freedom from government and you know
they haven't invented anything uh partly
because you know that's why they use
that name
anarco because they are anarchists and
they haven't invented anarchism for sure
you know
Anarchist U came to being in the 19th
century and early 20th century
especially you know and they they were
these guys who threw uh Molotov
Cocktails so everybody looks at a uh an
anarchist as a uh violent person in
general but these guys say no no we're
going to do it the Civilized way we're
going to do a narco capitalism you know
and so we're going to do it you know by
just ignoring the government trying to
get away from them and finding ways of
skirting taxes and all all these things
that they impose on us I'm going to try
to do our own thing on the side yeah you
can do that you can do it on your own
but the question is uh you know you're
you've got still the government there
how do you get rid of government is the
question and uh you know one of the guys
who tackled that was Marx himself col
Marx said hey you know communism this is
the way he envisioned it will evolve to
a point where at some point you know
there uh people are going to decide that
they don't need government anymore and
government itself will cease to exist he
saw the same thing he was
uh in the uh you know deep in his heart
he was an anarchist other words he said
let's do communism first and we'll work
our way you know through the
dictatorship of a proletarian we're
going to work our way to no government
to anarchism what he objected to his
imposing
anarchism you know Anarchy that same in
his days he said it's too early that's
more or less the way he looked at it and
so there were differences between the
anarchist and the Communist there in in
those in that sense but these people
haven't uh really um you know invented
anything uh they they want to get free
themselves from government and I wish
him good luck I don't think it's ever
going to happen especially when we're
running out of time what do we say here
in this Chanel we're the last generation
of humans on Earth and so I don't think
there's enough time for them to impose
this ideal Society where there is no
government you know I used to think in
those terms myself once you know saying
someday or it' be nice if there was a
world government and then World
Government itself ceases to exist yeah
great as a
dream uh another thing is reality and
achieving it okay anyways uh you know uh
primarily I want to say that in this
channel the best answer for this fellow
is that we don't we don't really do
politics okay I don't like to do
politics and I stopped doing politics a
long long time ago I'd say at least 30
years okay uh I don't do politics
meaning what is politics politics is
opinion and opinion is religion politics
is simply one kind of religion that's
all it is and uh because what is it
opinion some people like you know
candidate a the other guy likes
candidate B some people like Ukraine
other people like Russia some people
like uh Israel some people like the
Hamas or suffer for them some people
like the Aeris others like the you know
Armenians and
China and Taiwan and India and Pakistan
I mean it goes on and on and on should
you take sides you know people suffer
and they get all nervous they read the
news and they say look what's happening
over there look what happening over
there and they're killing people here
and they're killing people there and
they begin to take sides it turns out
you know if you know the solution is
very simple simple just turn your TV off
you know and forget it if it gets you
nervous it gets you excited hey turn
your TV off that's the solution to all
your problems you solve all the world
problems with that and you have to
remember also that the politicians they
don't care they do whatever they have to
and they do whatever they want they do
whatever is in their best interest and
I'll give you an example you know on the
one hand you have Netanyahu in Israel
and he says oh we're going to free the
hostages and he sends an army
to to beat up the people in Hamas and
try to recover you know rescue uh the
hostages and that's more or less like
you know someone is held hostage in a
house right and there's a gunman with
with a gun to the to the host's head and
you have all the police all around there
how do you think you're going to free
the guy you think you're going to free
the guy by you know storming the
house I doubt it because as soon as
someone gets into the first bullet goes
to that head and so you know it's not
the way you want to free people you know
so what they're doing now is just a lot
of lip service they're saying look we're
going to free the hostages and they're
doing it with the Army for sure they're
not going to free a single one if they
do it that way the only way to do that
is to negotiate right if you want to
really free the hostages so on the one
hand they say we want to free the
hostages and on the one hand they send
the Army that's on one side how about
the other side how about the Arab side
and this shows you why you should choose
sides the Arab side you have Iran and
Iran is is telling all the Arab
countries there and saying look you guys
want to be real you want to help Hamas
you you really root for the Arab world
very simple stop all Commerce with
Israel you know boycott Israel I mean
just like Europe and R and the United
States did with Russia right do the same
thing to Israel and what did the Arab
countries do and I'm talking about
several of them well they said uh we're
going to pull our ambassadors we're
going to withdraw our ambassadors in
protest well that's very cosmetic of you
you know why don't you do what Iran says
you know and says uh go in there and
boycott the economy then it's going to
hurt them but as long as you keep the
economy rolling you're just giving lip
service to saying that you are in favor
of the Hamas group and that you want you
really suffer for all those people so
the politicians on both side they just
play games and and all I can say is
you're a fool if you root for any of
them the best thing don't root for any
of them the politicians will do what
they have to do anyways whether you like
it or not so that's the way I see that
so yeah stay away from opinion here
here's a uh comparison who do you think
is best uh Bugs Moran north side of
Chicago 1930s there 1920 late 1920s
really uh or the Southside Al Capone I
mean who do you think uh should you
should root for okay should you go with
a North or with a
South well my suggestion is um you know
don't go with any of them they're all
mafias and uh same with all these
politicians they'll do whatever they
have to do anyway so it doesn't uh help
you to lose a single drop of feeling for
any of that and again if you do uh just
turn your TV off you'll have it soled
okay so is Argentina the only place in
the world got problems well here uh let
me show you something this is Iraq okay
and it says Iraq scrambles to contain
fighting between US troops and Iran back
groups fearing Gaza spillover okay and
it says there listen to this is Baghdad
uh relies heavily on Washington sanction
waivers to buy electricity from Iran and
since the you the 2003 US invasion
Iraq's foreign currency reserves have
been housed at the US Federal Federal
Reserve Iraq's money is in New
York giving the Americans significant
control over Iraq's supply of dollars
the United States extended Iraq
sanctions waiver by four months to
purchase Iranian electricity Washington
has used the sanctions waiver as one of
its cards you know pressure points in an
economy centered efforts to pressure
Iran and Iraq okay and here you see uh
what kind of effect that has uh people
go out into the streets because they're
having economic problems okay and again
it says for months the United States has
restricted Iraq's access to its own
dollar trying to stamp out what Iraqi
officials describe as rampant money
laundering that benefits Iran and Syria
okay and so it goes on and on the point
here is that you know um all these
countries depend on the United States so
you wonder how come the United States
has so much power in negotiating power
Pol itics and so on because it controls
a lot of the money that these people
need and the governments maybe have
idealistic people in their in their
country you know nationalistic and so on
and religious Fanatics and so on and
they have to cater to them if they want
to stay in power but at the same time
they have to be you know they have to
shake hands with both the devil and God
you know and so they have to cater also
to the United States and say look we're
doing our best here to keep the crowds
down and so on so you know they have all
these uh pressures from above and below
and they try to you know walk on Middle
Line uh partly for their own personal
interest right that's the way politics
works so again you should not put any
heart any feeling behind any of this
stuff and Iraq's the only one Argentina
are the only ones well take a look
here says India Brazil and Mexico India
Brazil Mexico and Indonesia could emerge
as engines of global growth one one
liner that I found around there right
and so you look at these and say okay
let's see how well these people are
doing and the reason they mentioned
those four countries is they're highly
populated there's a lot of population
there uh says here uh India uh for
example Brazil economic growth will be
just 2.8 in 2022 and 1.2 in 2023 the
current economic crisis right there's a
crisis there has had a severe effect on
the Brazilian labor market in 2021 the
world uh Bank calculated
14.4% of working AG Brazilians were
unemployed and I would say it's higher
because all those people who work in
services are also unemployed okay is
Indonesia doing any better okay another
very popular country uh I think third or
fourth in the world the three key
economic challenges for the indones iian
government are controlling inflation
providing job opportunities through
Investments and maintaining growth how
about Pakistan another populous country
is faced with a number of economic
challenges with which include a balance
of payment crisis soaring inflation
mounting debt obligations and persistent
budget deficit and then we look at
Nigeria the biggest economy in Africa in
the continent of Africa followed by
Egypt and South Africa and it says
persistent to reach a 17-year high of
25.8% in August 2023 which in
combination with sluggish growth is
leaving millions of Nigerians in
poverty okay uh so how are all these
countries doing I think they're all
doing terrible there's not a single
country on the planet that's doing good
and you might say well that's always
been like that through
history uh this is new what we have
today is new and uh I keep saying you
know the reason it's new is that we're
in a different type of eon uh economic
mode economic mode we're in the service
economy before we were in you know
manufacturing and before that we were in
agriculture service economy totally
different ball game okay uh the most
advanced Nations on the planet have 80
85% of their economy is Services what is
Services Services is another word for
unemployment you don't do anything
you're not producing ing anything you
know you look from the sky you look down
on the earth you see what's constructed
you see the material things that have
been constructed and and made you don't
see the promises you don't see the bank
accounts you don't see Insurance you
know all those any other service that
you can think of you know those are not
there service is unemployment there's
nothing being produced and you judge a
country's expansion by you know how much
uh progress you see in the material
things okay and so uh all I can tell you
is
that uh you know there's a lot of
unemployment and we're creating more
services and less manufacturing which is
be a lot of it being replaced by robots
by the way and more efficiency and um
agriculture in the most advanced Nations
is like 1% of their GDP so uh just keep
all that in mind uh the global economy
is not doing well at all and what is
what do we say here here we're going to
say that the global economy is at some
point going to collapse we cannot grow
forever partly we cannot grow forever
because population doesn't grow forever
in fact population has been it's not
declining it's still growing but it's
growing at an Ever slower rate and we
will reach zero population growth on the
planet as a whole uh probably by
mid-century if things continue as they
are now that means that companies that
EXP expect more demand tomorrow more
customers well they're going to be out
of luck because there's going to be
fewer and fewer marginal you know uh
increases in in um in population that
means you're going to have less and less
demand over time at some point there's
going to be a crisis that cannot be
solved just by creating money or just
modifying the money supply or anything
like that any fiscal or monetary policy
will fail you just can't put people to
work uh
in un unnecessary jobs and we're going
to reach that stage I think and that
that point uh at some point money will
be no more in fact we're having a very
interesting situation in
Argentina where people can barely make
it to the end of the month and the
government is now giving a bonus between
50,000 and 80,000 pesos which is about
50 to $80 to keep them running till the
end of the month that's how bad things
are over there and you say Well that's
just Argentina but that's going to come
to a lot of countries when they reach a
certain level where they can't grow
anymore because you know you can't have
just external Investments because a lot
of that also takes money out of the
country right and so on there's there's
this play but just to make a long story
short I'm just saying you cannot keep
growing forever economically okay and at
that point at some point right there no
matter how much money they give you will
not be able to make till the end of the
month and even the workers you know they
receive money and they barely make it
till the end of the month they can
barely pay rent and also food and at
some point there there's going to be
such a crisis that people will say hey
money is worthless I don't want that
money anymore I I want something real
like food you know and it would be the
fight between the halves and have knots
the halves will be those who have food
and have knots will be those that
don't okay that's uh in a nutshell what
I have to say about that but again we
don't do politics here I'm not
interested in politics the only reason I
mentioned politics is in relation to
Extinction that's the only time I put
economics and politics into uh into the
conversation other other than that I'm
not interested in either subject in uh
in any specific way you know okay
another subject that came up and that's
I'm going to close with this and here it
is this ppar stuff as a scientist
surprised by samples recovered from
ancient asteroid asteroid name is benu
or benu among the findings from the
early benu analysis are what could be
the building blocks of life organic
compounds containing carbon carbon or
carbon hydrogen bonds meteorites found
on Earth have had similar compounds and
as nature explains those carbon-rich
minerals may have contributed to life on
our planet okay and so what are we
talking about we're talking about you
know little bugs crawling on a um on an
asteroid and having a free trip down
here to earth right and so what is this
panspermia well here it is here's the
definition from the Wikipedia says the
hypothesis that life exists throughout
the Universe distrib distributed by
space dust
meteoroids uh asteroids comets
planetoids as well as by spacecraft
carrying unintended contamination by
micro or organisms uh known as directed
panspermia okay the theory argues that
life did not originate on Earth but
instead evolved somewhere else and
seated Life as we know it and this is
what P spia requires says uh that life
has always existed in the universe
somewhere and we have no problem with
that one because we're saying the
universe was eternal there was no never
a first living entity in the universe so
we agree with this uh except we have a
different context for it okay organic
molecules originated in space perhaps to
be distributed to Earth absolutely not
life originated from these molecules
extraterrestrial well there is
extraterrestrial life out there I'm
convinced of that but uh that doesn't
mean that number four is correct which
is this extr terrestial life was
transported to Earth okay here we
maintain that
um
um you know life cannot no living entity
can travel Interstellar let alone
intergalactically okay it's impossible
it's just beyond Mother Nature never
intended for that to happen neither did
Father universe so here we have uh what
these people say that let me illustrate
this here it
goes you see the little bug on a
asteroid okay some kind of bug some kind
of living entity it doesn't matter and
asteroid comes to earth right and
somehow you know lands you could say
collides we can say has a soft Landing
no problem and the bug now you know
travels within the Earth maybe on a
branch of a tree you know and he gave
life to all of us eventually right okay
it's not that kind of a bug that we're
talking about obviously uh I'm just
showing that there's a living entity
traveling on on a rock right and no it's
impossible it's impossible first because
the Rope uh does not allow okay for any
rope model of light does not allow for
any living entity to travel to the
nearest star okay you can send robots
yeah that could happen but not living
entities okay and living uh is that
which moves by itself without the you
know artificial not not artificial I
mean natural uh that uh moves Against
Gravity moves against the uh path of
least resistance
okay anyways the point here is that I
think uh the world is about to collapse
very soon the global economy when not if
but when that happens well we're all um
screwed uh it's the end of man it's the
end of our species and someday I think
we have to end why not sooner than later
I mean do we get to choose uh or does
Mother Nature get to choose when humans
disappear from the face of the Earth and
with humans the whole m
order uh disappears as well and uh
that's what happened to the dinosaurs
you know and part of the reason for that
is that we're going to liquidate any
living entity before we go we're going
to eat it okay so get ready for the next
few years something might happen and I
think it's going to be sooner than
rather than later that's my 5 cents
worth on
that okay let's move on to uh the
subject matter of today and it's going
to be in the physics department and
we're going to do uh what we're going to
do a little bit of block Universe again
time travel but time dilation and uh you
know stretching of time we stretch this
thing we call time mathematicians love
to deal with time because they can do
whatever they want with time in their
equations and the funny part about it is
your where you can start is that they
never Define the word time they still
don't have an idea what the word time is
is means right what the definition of
time is they cannot Define it but here
everybody uses it puts it in the
equations and then gives you what's
worse a physical interpretation see they
can do whatever they want in their
equations that's a description but when
they jump the fence and come into
physics and try to give you a physical
interpretation of the equation that's
where we have a problem you know because
these people say they are physicists
which they are not they are
mathematicians but then they give you a
physical inter interpretation which
belongs strictly to physics they say it
doesn't they say that physics is about
equations and if that's the case and why
do they even attempt to give a physical
interpretation I mean if it's not part
of their job description it's not part
of their uh you know their job
functions uh why have they tried to give
you a physical interpretation they're
not experts at physical
interpretations and so why did they do
do that well I'll tell you why because
if they didn't their equations are
totally meaningless
worthless if you cannot relate your
equation to the real world and tell me
how the world Works whether or without
your equation your equation is worthless
and that's where we stand today they
give you an irrational explanation when
you criticize them and say look you know
I call your bluff um time does not
dilate you cannot travel through time
and you tell them all this stuff there
is no such thing as a block universe
they say well you
know uh that's not part of our what we
do what we do is equations then why did
you attempt to do it why did you give me
this bogus you know uh explanation of
how the universe works you know the
mechanism the
explanation when you're not an expert at
it when you later on dismiss it as
saying well it's not part of our job
description anyways so why did you try
and this is the problem this is they
they sell it to you like if they know
they sell it to you on the basis of
authority and then they take it back
when you call their Bluff okay and here
uh we we did a little bit of this the
other day going to go quickly through a
little review here we have a good old uh
Brian Green there you know brain green
and what does brain green do he jumps
into a wormhole and he ends up early in
the morning where he meets himself so he
traveled through time from evening or
noon to uh morning and he gets to see
himself so he says you can do this
easily by just jumping into a wormhole
such a cinch you know no problem at all
okay so um this is not the only just in
case you know you say well maybe he was
just uh talking out of hand or whatever
no no he he he rubbed it in in his uh I
can't remember this was from the elegant
universe or another uh bit of um
uh another series that he had um this is
another thing that he showed in that
series and here let me show it to
you here he goes watch
carefully he meets the girl you know
that meets him at the airport or the
Jetport or the space port and he takes
off goes into outer space and travels to
a u a black hole he's going to go around
the black hole there and turn the corner
and come right back okay so he comes
back okay and when he comes back um you
know he uh arrives uh here at um to meet
the uh the same girl and she's a little
older now you know and so the question
is you know is this possible does this
make any sense that he just traveled and
uh you know to a black hole and comes
back and and she's the same girl but
she's not a girl anymore she's an old
lady but he Remains the Same he's you
know he hasn't changed a bit does that
make any sense and they say well it
makes sense in a black universe that you
can travel through time because you know
you can travel forward in like in this
case you know he traveled to the Future
right I don't care how he explain that
it doesn't matter to me what his
mathematics is is irrelevant to me I'm
just saying that he traveled to the UN
to the Future that what he claims and he
says that's possible NASA says it's
possible CERN says it's possible all
mathematicians on Earth say it's
possible okay so we have this travel to
the Future it's possible right and um uh
I showed this the other day here let me
show you this give me a second here and
it's this a skater and this fellow is
gonna um you know someone's filming him
and this is how it looks okay here it
goes the guy skates okay normal and now
you can see what's happening to uh to
all these all these uh we'll call him
Joe to all these Joe's okay so Joe we
have all these pictures of him little by
little
right and here you see the whole
sequence okay so uh is this possible I
mean what's the problem here well the
problem here is that you see the guy at
a right which is Joe at a and the same
guy Joe at B okay that's what the
problem is and why is it a problem well
because they say that all these Joe's
exist simultaneously in the block
Universe okay so the black Universe
you're not seeing time what you're
seeing is a still image where everybody
coexists at the same time past present
and future that's what the black
universe is and the only way you can
produce that is if there is no motion
whatsoever first of all because it's a
block universe that you can see in one
shot only that's the first issue the
other one is that there can't be Anem
motion because what they're saying is
they're creating matter they're creating
matter they're creating new Joe's at
every location there so Joe from a is
not moving all the way to B what's
happening is uh new Joe's are being
created in between and so there is no
motion and they all exist at the same
time so that if you could travel because
I don't know how you can travel in a
black Universe it's made of a single
piece right but let's assume you could
travel you know you're the only guy who
can move you move and you can see any of
those frames because they're still there
that's why you can see them there you
can shake hands with any of those guys
because they're still there the atoms
are still there that's what they're
saying and the only way you can have
that is that you know if you created all
these new atoms of Joe that make up Joe
okay so this is this is the big problem
that we have
there okay so um here we have good old
uh uh brain
green and this is what he proposed he
says this is the block Universe okay and
all those lines that you see there the
white lines coming down those are slices
of
time but we have a problem with slices
of time because time is not a slice not
a like they try to say it's a thin slice
no it's not a thin slice it's a slice
that has no thickness at all it's zero
thin or zero width zero length whatever
um you know it has no no width at all
whatsoever that slice it's a
cross-section of time it's a
cross-section of motion each one of
those lines there represents location
each one of those slices represents
location it's a static
concept and they say well that's time
and that's where the first problem comes
in because time requires at least two
frames of the movie right of the
universal movie and here they're talking
about a single slice which is a single
frame of the universal movie and that's
where we start with problems okay uh so
what is the problem the problem is this
let me show you here which I showed you
the other
day here we have uh atoms and you would
think that if you film these five atoms
these are the you know five atoms in the
universe just taking it random and you
can see they're moving in the frame
within the frame right so you say okay
they're moving right if I were to run
this in a movie camera you know some
kind uh you would see the uh atoms
moving from left to right okay and
they're moving ever more towards the
right okay but that's not what these
people say in the black Universe what
they're saying is that they're creating
matter they're creating these atoms
they're duplicating each one of those
atoms and what you're really seeing is
this you're seeing that each atom is
being
produced uh actually not even from frame
to frame like I'm showing there I'm just
that I just Illustrated so that you can
see what these people are saying they're
saying that the previous atom never
moved it's always there and the only
frame that really exists is uh frame
number 457 in fact someone asked the
question says um uh well here uh you see
that all these other frames they're just
imaginary you know they don't exist
according to the black Universe the
black Universe only includes that last
frame 457 and that's the only frame for
the black
Universe okay and um so if we were to
put the skater now you'll see that you
know all these other frames that were
there they're not really there according
to the the black Universe the only uh
the only frame that exists is the one
457 there on the right that's what
they're saying and they're saying that
all these atoms were created instead of
having their be any motion no we created
all these atoms of Joe and he's he's in
the entire picture in other words the
block universe is a photograph it's not
a dynamic concept okay so uh I hope
you're understanding what I'm saying
here
okay okay so where does this all lead uh
well here uh all these frames exist okay
um and uh there you see uh frame number
457 that's the present we'll call that
the present and that's you there and we
have an atom in your shoulder that red
one there kind of big right but just
just illustrating there and the question
is can you travel to frame
154 and talk to yourself can that atom
be at two places at once can it be at
frame 457 and also at frame 154 that's
the question we're asking right and one
fell asked that question in fact he said
uh the following said that frame 154 he
says here it is says that frame uh 154
exists only in memory right and that's
true it only exists in your memory you
know sometimes you film it and you say
well it's in the film yeah it's in the
film but the film is in the present so
it's not like you're looking at the past
you're you're you're looking at
something was kept in memory in some
kind of memory it could be a device
could be your your brain you know but
it's kept in memory but it doesn't exist
out there for real that atom is already
gone because it's now at a different
location that's what it is okay so yeah
frame number 154 does not exist there's
nothing there
okay and uh so here it is uh you know
frame 154 does not exist what exists is
only what is in frame 457 the present
okay and all the other frames both
before and after the future as well they
don't exist they're not there why
because that frame 457 only has Lo a
existence and if you remember um you
know from the universal movie existance
and location are static Concepts you do
not need to move in order to exist you
do not need to move in order to have
location location is a static concept so
it's existence what is existence an
object with location and that is in a
single frame that's what we call
existence people who don't like the
definition have a very easy task all
they have to do is Define the word
existence and then we'll know what
they're talking about until then you
know you have to accept the definition
the scientific definition that we
propose
here okay so um here we go with this um
follow
says uh time travel dilates time he says
travel dilates time they're talking in
these terms they say it dilates time
they you see time bending it's dilating
I guess getting bigger or whatever 5
years on a ship traveling at 99% the
speed of light 2.5 years out and 2.5
years back corresponds to roughly 36
years on
Earth five years in space equal 36 years
on Earth okay that's what he says this
this is what they talk about and the
answer is no first of all absolutely not
true you know and this is very easily
shown I don't care where you go you can
go into a black hole and come come back
if you want you can go through a
wormhole to another universe and come
back we don't care uh the year is
defined as one revolution of the Earth
around the Sun okay so uh the Earth went
around the Sun either five times or 36
times when the guy gets back so he can't
have it both ways either either the
Earth went around the Sun five times or
it went around the Sun 36 times one of
the two persons is is wrong they say
well I took my atomic clock with me and
I measured time with you know precise
seconds well first of all there are not
such thing as precise seconds and we
shown that with GPS because uh clocks
run a little differently up there than
they do down here so uh I don't care how
accurate your atomic clock is as soon as
you travel outside the earth going into
space well all bets are off your your
clock is going to tick at a different
rate so we don't know what it's ticking
but again we don't Define uh the year
counting seconds on an atomic clock the
way we Define the word year so we know
whether you are 40 years old or 45 years
old or 50 years old you know how many
candles we put on your cake uh the way
we do it is by Revolutions of the Earth
around the Sun and again either that's
the best clock there is for the word
year okay and so either the Earth went
around the Sun either five times or 36
times one of the two guys is wrong and
hopefully it's the guy who traveled okay
so we don't care what that guy
measured uh when he comes back to Earth
he better have the same number of
revolutions around the Sun as the guy
that was on earth right can't be both
ways that's the way we measure time we
don't we don't use these fancy clocks
that the mathematicians use to confuse
themselves okay so here we have a good
old Brian again and um let's put him on
again here he goes he's going to travel
to that uh black hole okay and he goes
out there and then um he comes back well
we'll wait for him to come back okay
that's two and a half years
right round trip uh five years right
goes around the uh black hole comes back
and gets to see the girl again okay no
longer a girl okay
and now he's uh back on Earth and he
sees what he's going to see this old
lady and that was the same girl that he
left now the strange thing for me about
this is that um you know that um I was
surprised that uh they still had uh
check-in agents in the future you know
so many years into the future you would
think that in the next 20 years they
won't have any check-in agents at the
airport anymore but that was I mean
surrealistic for me but okay what is
good O'Brien good brain green saying you
well here it is he's saying that he goes
from slice a to slice B sometime into
the future he stays the same you can see
he hasn't changed much but the girl man
boy she she suffered quite a bit time
really was uh you know very harsh on her
okay and so we we have a problem with
this because you're saying okay is this
true does this make any sense that he
stayed the same and she changed so we're
not only talking about time travel here
we're talking about physical biological
changes have we really changed uh have
we do we really think that someone
changes
biologically uh in this sense that just
because they travel outside the Earth
and come back okay I mean you could say
that his clock went wrong you know that
his uh atomic clock had uh measured
wrong because it was at an outer space
moving around Etc does that mean the guy
uh is physically different or that that
affects him physically like biologically
to such an extent that he remains more
or less the same you know very little
change in his appearance whereas the
persons on Earth aged you know 40 50
years more than he did you know and so
uh again no common sense there and of
course when you point that out to the
mathematicians they say well that's uh
philosophy of science anyway we don't
care about that well then why did you
why did you try to convince me of it you
know why did you try
to you know send sell me this U this
Bluff you know and when I call
your call your cards you you don't know
what to put on the table because uh you
don't have an answer you rational answer
okay so how do we tackle this problem
about time dilation and time travel and
uh stretching time and playing around
with the word time well the first way
way you can do this the best way you
know know the first step is to find the
definition of the word time I mean let's
what what are we talking about what is
time what is this thingy we call time
you know and so here's a fellow and he
went out there and he looked at a couple
dictionaries and he puts this he says
from camridge time is what we measure in
minutes hours days Etc okay it's what we
measure okay great whatever that is you
know uh Oxford what is measured in
minutes ours days long man the thing
that is measured in minutes hours days
years Etc okay and branic the thing that
is measured as seconds minutes Etc so
they all say the same thing it's a
measuring of seconds minutes hours years
whatever whatever that is I mean what is
that what do you mean you measured hours
what does that mean you know uh what did
you measure hours what is that I thought
the hours is defined as as time you know
how are you going to Define hour except
using the word time and if you define
the word time using the word hours or
minutes or second you're just running
around in circles okay so let's go to a
uh more because that came out I guess
primarily from Google you know the guy
just searched Google and found those
fine no problem those are the
dictionaries what the dictionary say
here let's go to an official site here's
the nist nist is the National Institute
of Standards okay and this is a fell
who's worked many years 37 years working
on developing atomic clocks of the
future has been the focus of my career
over the past 30 years okay so he tries
to answer what then is time okay okay so
here we have an expert okay fortunately
finally time appears to be the most
bizarre of our basic units time is a
slippery creature now that's a terrible
way to start a presentation right St
Augustine remarked uh when what then is
time if no one ask me I know what it is
if I wish to explain it to him who asks
I do not know okay that's great so St
Augustine had no idea what time was how
about any he says concluded after much
thought that time is what clocks measure
which was what time seconds minutes
hours years right okay so we haven't
learned much from Einstein either okay
and then he continues says whatever time
is for reasons for which I still puzzle
so he still doesn't know what time is we
can measure the pth mage of time
precisely so he all he does is
measurement but he still has no idea
what time is he cannot Define the word
time and he just measures it whatever
that is whatever he's measuring and he
says time is the accumulation of
identical repeatable events uh yeah I
guess that's uh when you see Joe in
every
frame repeatable right time might be the
ultimate Motion in other words he has no
clue here's a guy who studied it for 30
years he has no idea what he's measured
measuring he he has no idea what time
is and this guy's at nist he's got a PhD
Etc so the question is here you have
these gurus they talk about time and
they have no idea what time is and so
here we have one of our
um uh follows here uh his name is um M
Dow okay and he works for PBS he does
this program called
SpaceTime and he's going to tell us
everything about time that you always
wanted to know you were afraid to ask
okay and so here it is and he starts his
presentation a little bit on the wrong
foot okay so here it is he starts out
and yeah he's really a caricature of
physicist he's really a mathematical
physics he doesn't know anything about
physics and here you can see we're going
to start out by me totally convincing
you oh so his uh job is not to explain
something to you in a rational manner
manner he's here as a prosecutor trying
to convince you of something okay so his
job is not to explain or say something
rational he's just trying to convince
you great sounds like religion to me
that time must run slow in a
gravitational field mass and energy
change the lengths of rulers and the
speeds of clocks mass and energy two
concepts and they change speeds of
clocks I wonder how mass and energy do
it I mean these are Concepts I mean how
is does a kilogram right Mass how does a
kilogram change the speed of a clock I
mean does IT smash it or what says the
curvature in the fabric of space is the
cause of
gravitation ahuh so he says curvature of
the fabric of space well space is not a
fabric space is nothing space is the
same thing as vacuum as nothing they're
synonyms nothing means it has no
shape no Dimensions no um volume no um
radius no diameter no nothing that's
what space is nothing and so how can you
have the curvature of nothing but he
says that's what causes gravitation okay
over the course of your life your feet
will age one second more than your head
due to gravitational time dilation okay
so your feet are older than your head
this is what this uh we call them
scientists what do you call this guy
well we call them
idiots and you say you're insulting the
guy and no no I'm not I'm I'm treating
him with the respect that he deserves if
this guy studied 10 years at the
University to come and tell you that
your feet are older than your head he's
got to be if he really believes that
he's got to go to psychiatrist and
otherwise he should be laughed off the
stage yeah that's how simple it is
you're held in your chair right now by
the curvature of time the curvature of
time what is this Bean brain talking
about what do you you mean how can time
curve what is he talking about you're
held down because your butt is ticking
faster than your
head and yeah uh I didn't invent this
this comes out of his video okay this is
what he this is how he starts his
presentation okay so uh not a very good
way to start a conversation you know uh
a scientific presentation scientific
dissertation saying that your butt is
glued to your chair because time is
curved what does that even mean what is
he talking about and again when they
dismiss and say well that's philosophy
no no why did you even try to convince
me that's just what he was trying to do
he was trying to convince us right TR to
persuade convince recruit us telling us
that he knows he's an authority and this
is what he comes up with okay let's see
let's see how it continues then he goes
out he says is all that exists now
whatever exists right now
now the answer lies between the past and
the future in The elusive ever moving
eye blink that we call the present well
it's not an Ever moving because uh the
present is not anything that's moving so
we need to find out what the present is
okay and until he can Define the present
he cannot say it's uh moving time or or
the moving present okay the present
doesn't move okay and uh
if we're talking about now the present
we got to Define we got to have an idea
what this present this now means
otherwise we don't know what he's
talking about he can just give us all
this verbiage you know and we have no
idea what he's talking about okay so
here he goes he says uh Newton's picture
of the universe included one assumption
that we know for sure is wrong okay what
is that the idea of an absolute clearly
definable
now in other words he's saying you
cannot Define the word now you cannot
Define the word present that's what he's
saying okay and he says Newton failed
because you know we know that there's no
way that you can Define the word now
that's how he starts okay so he says
Newton assumed that all particles all
observers all points in space were ruled
by a single constantly ticking clock
this universal clock meant it that it
was possible to define a notion of now
that everyone would agree on well we
don't care about agreement in science we
do not agree one thing is uh to Define
itself so that it's can be used
consistently rationally and in other
words in an objective Manner and he who
doesn't like the definition or has a
better one okay uh you know comes up
with a better mouse trap or keep your
trap shut okay just like that it's very
simple this is not a question of
agreeing this is a question of defining
in such a way that you can use the word
consistently that we know what the word
now means or the word present
means okay so uh we look up the word now
or present and this is what we find out
there Oxford Wikipedia and Miriam
Webster dictionaries right the present
the period of time now occurring okay
what is now now at the present time or
moment so now is the present present now
great we've learned a lot we have these
synonyms there right uh Wei says the
period of time that is occurring now
what is now the present
time and present I'm sorry Miriam
Webster now existing or in progress what
is now at the present time or moment
so all they did was run around in
circles we have no definition of now or
present and so Mr odow was right in that
sense nobody in mathematics the religion
of mathematics mathematical physics
people who studied for 10 years and got
a PhD not one of them can tell you what
the word now or the word present or the
word time mean they have no idea so they
start talking about them they tell you
all these great things about now in the
present and time and not one of them
have been able to define those three
words in the last 100 years okay really
in the last 10,000 years okay how does
this follow continue here he goes he
says we only experience a single slice
at a
time the one that currently exists okay
so we have a contradiction there because
he says single slice at a time and he's
saying that it's the only one that
exists exist is a static concept you
don't need to move to exist he says it's
a single slice of time but time requires
two frames so he's got a contradiction
either the single slice exists or it's
moving through time as they say you know
it it takes up either it takes up one
frame in the word exist or it takes up
two or more frames in the word time it
can't be both and there he starts with
that contradiction he doesn't even
understand what he said there right or
his contradiction the Paradox that he's
created there but then he continues says
we can imagine a perspective from out
outside of both space and time in which
this entire structure just
exists okay so he's saying that it's a
structure meaning this whole uh what
he's going to call the block Universe
exists in a single structure well then
he's not talking about time he's saying
there is no such thing as time in this
structure okay it just exists which is
correct I mean if he's going to talk
about the block Universe it just exists
there is no such thing as time so he
cannot lay divide it like brain green
did by cutting it into slices of time no
those are slices of locations if
anything right but not of time from that
perspective time does not have a
particular direction and there's no
preferred present well we don't know
about preferred that's an irrelevant
term uh we don't care if it's preferred
or not preferred if it's good or bad
those are quality uh um qualifiers that
we do not use in science time is us a
dimension like space and we only observe
the flow of time now he's talking about
the flow of time and then he talks about
existence of time so either flows or it
exists if we play these slices in
sequence like a flip book okay well he
can't do that because he's saying it
it's a single
block and we use the term block Universe
to refer to this view of all space and
time just existing in this
four-dimensional
chunk so we have a problem because
they're mixing um Dynamic Concepts such
as flow right that something is moving
with an existing chunk that you can see
in one shot so either we're talking
about something emotional we're talking
about something that is static and they
don't realize their contradiction they
just use these terms because again they
never Define the word time the word
present the word now they don't Define
these terms they just use them they say
you know and and yeah so they they have
this block Universe a single block right
in front of you you can see the whole
block but they talk about time moving
through that block well if it's single
block then what you're doing is putting
a movie within a picture which is
totally irrational you're saying that
you know the Mona Lisa is smiling within
the picture but for smile smile is a
verb you need at least two frames of the
movie I mean you know you have the movie
of Mona Lisa smiling you know you can
see her face changing her mouth changing
her eyes changing but you can't see that
in a photograph and these people are
saying saying that Mona Lisa Smiles
within the photograph they're saying
that the black Universe exists within a
single photograph in which time is
moving so we have a problem there
serious problem with that so what's he
talking about well he's talking about
something like this okay where God looks
at the uh block Universe there right
those white lines coming down you know
up and down those are time slices as
they call them they're really location
slices and uh you know God can see them
from Heaven I guess you can see the
whole block Universe in one shop well if
you can see it all in one shop then
those lines there cannot be slices that
are moving across the screen because
either we have a static image or we have
something in motion if I want to see
that in motion I need many frames of the
film I cannot see it in a single frame
as you see there okay so this is where
the contradiction lies okay and uh he
continues he says the following these
are uh this is how he's coming up with
all this stuff he says to us none of the
rest of the black Universe exists
because our existence emerges from the
forward evolution of a razor thin slice
so he kind of defining existence there
he's saying that it's an emerging
property that has to do with a forward
evolution of a razor thin slice that's
more or less how he defines existence
he's defining existence with motion he's
embodying motion into the word existence
okay so he's saying existence is an
object that moves and we say existence
is an object that has location existence
is a static concept not a dynamic one
says the perception of existing in a
single instant in time is definitely an
illusion well that is the definition of
existing existing means that you exist
in a single frame of the universal movie
uh but this guy says it's time Time and
Time requires two frames okay so you
exist in two frames So when you say that
uh that I exist uh what he's saying is
that you're you're in two frames at once
you're in frame 457 was it and 458
you're in both frames because in order
to exist you have to move from one frame
to the other that's what he's saying in
his special relativity theory of
relativity Einstein show that there is
no absolute way to define whether two
events happen simultaneously how do even
say that now what what now means for
other parts of the universe uhhuh so he
says we cannot define this word now why
because it takes um time right or motion
for uh an image from that other side of
the universe to reach your eyes so he's
saying did that happen at the same time
that I'm staring at it but that's not
the issue the issue is the question is
the word now the word present and the
word time and again he hasn't defined
them but if we talk about now what are
we talking about okay that's that's what
we got to figure out what the word now
and the word present mean what what is
the scientific definition of now what is
the defin scientific definition of
present so that we can use it
consistently in a conversation this guy
is all over the place he's talking about
meaning
motion uh uh Observer you know you have
to wait for the image to reach you and
then you don't know if it happened now
or it happened before or later or
whatever and then uh and then he hasn't
defined a present or time either right
nothing not even information can travel
faster than night we don't care about
that uh even though it's true yeah that
means that any distant event is already
in the past by the time we see it
irrelevant totally irrelevant what we're
talking about now and not uh now when it
happened okay either either we talk
about now Pres or we talk about uh
happening happening requires two frames
now and present single frame they static
Concepts the present the now is right
now one frame of the film okay okay so
here it is
um uh you know this is uh from Good Old
brain green again and he's saying that
you have all these time slices in the
Universal uh block Universe right and
yeah again we have a problem because uh
you can see we need a movie to see all
these time slices and how they're coming
up one after another and that's not what
he showed he showed he says that you can
see this whole thing in a single picture
and so we have a contradiction between
what they illustrate and what they're
saying they're saying you can see it all
in one picture and here you see many
pictures you see many frames okay so
they do have a
contradiction okay so uh why don't we
Define this famous word time and uh
not so much time but present and now
what are what are the scientific
definitions of these words and here it
is okay here's the scientific version
okay present now it's a static concept
okay and uh they involved only location
location is a static concept it it also
involves existence existence is a static
concept you don't need to move to exist
okay so what's the present location of
every atom in the universe okay
single frame of the universal movie so
in one frame the yellow Concepts there
they're all static Concepts you have
object distance location existence and
we can add now you know present and now
that's what present now mean whatever is
in that picture a single frame that's
now and it only involves location
between atoms in the
universe um and um they're not what you
see on the bottom there time time is a
dynamic Concept in order to
conceptualize time you need at least two
frames of the movie therefore now is
not part of time okay now is just a
single frame in the movie okay time on
the other hand uh first you require
motion you can't have time without
motion and time is simply a comparison
of two
motions so uh that's you need to require
memory okay so uh what are the
conclusions from Mr odow he says
consider the time slice of your present
okay okay we're in the present it's a
Time slice so hopefully there's nothing
moving in that present right we can
imagine other observers on that time
slice that surely must exist again he's
talking a single slice meaning uh
nothing's moving really because he's
talking about time but really he's
talking about location and and he says
everything nothing moving uh you have
observers on that same slice which is a
slice of location in the universe every
atom just has distance with respect to
all other atoms in the universe that's
all we have it's hard to accept that
only the present exists which is what he
just defying in other words what we're
talking about is location that is the
present okay that only the current slice
of the black Universe has meaningful
reality because it is impossible to
Define what that slice actually is what
do you mean it's impossible I just
defined it I'm saying it's location it's
location of every atom in the universe
that's your slice of what he called time
which is really a slice of uh motion
location that's what that is it's just
location it's also hard to accept that
only the past exists and the future
doesn't because the present of someone
else on your slice of present could be
literally any point in your future
absolutely not because now he's talking
about motion he's saying I'm going to
move to the Future right and I'm going
to meet this guy that uh took me time
took me motion to get there right and so
he's saying it took me motion by the
time I get there well you know uh time
has passed and now are we talking about
his now my now everybody's now uh his
present my present you know so they get
get all mixed up with all this stuff now
it's very simple all you have to do is
cut a slice and find out what's in that
slice in other words what is in the
single frame of the universal movie you
got to stop the universe then you'll
know what now is and you'll know what
present is and what it is is one atom
located with respect to all other atoms
in the universe and hopefully unlike
they say with time travel you know that
atom cannot move to the past and find
itself in another frame because that
means that you're creating atoms all
along for every frame you're creating
new atoms you're not you're not moving
you're really static
in the black universe and all you did
was because you were able to move
somehow you were able to go and see that
same atom at a different location inside
the black universe and again all that's
irrational but that takes 10 years at
the University getting a PhD really at a
monastery and then you'll understand it
until you do you'll never understand it
yeah it's called brainwashing or what he
said what th said at the beginning I'm
here to convince you okay that's what
they do
with that I'll see you uh I'll be seeing
you on the 25th because on the 24th
we're going to be celebrating so I'll
see you on Monday the 25th